in mha most people have a quirk but the
absolutely strongest Quirk monsters have
the rare ability to use multiple quirks
to crush their opponents with ease in
this video I will break down the 13
strongest multiple Quirk users in the
series and trust me the top five will
surprise you so let's get into it
kicking off with spinner who had a total
of three quirks spinner wasn't really
all that when we were first introduced
to him but later on during the final Arc
he became an absolute unit thanks to the
two quirks that were given to him by All
For One his original Quirk was gecko
gecko mutates the user into a reptile
creature with the ability to cling to
walls and other flat surfaces spinner
has great hadian strength as geckos can
stay hooked onto services and motion
such as fast moving cars Spinner's Quirk
is at its strongest in urban areas with
a high density of buildings and walls
however gecko is regarded as a weak and
mediocre Quirk outside of urban areas
spinner doesn't have many opportunities
to use his Quirk due to environmental
constraints now in preparation for the
final war all for one gave spinner two
additional quirks body bulk and scale
mail body bulk allows spinner to bulk up
his whole body enhancing both his size
and strength however since gaining body
bulk he has become more mentally
unstable as a result of the stress of
having numerous quirks scale male allows
its user to wrap their entire body with
sharp armored scales increasing their
strength and defense the process of
producing the scales required for
defense causes the user to bleed when
the skin is ruptured because the armor
plate cannot sustain powerful punches
any High force of impact can quickly
break through it as demonstrated by
shi's OCTA spansion followed by present
Mike's voice assault however because
this Quirk has only been demonstrated to
be used by someone other than its
original owner it is unclear if these
are natural limitations of The Quirk or
a side consequence of it being used by
an incompatible body next up in the
power scale is the usj nomu the usj nomu
is an upper tier nomu who emerged as one
of the primary villains of the usj arc
alongside the league of villains as an
upper tier nomu the nomu has proven to
be very powerful and one of the
strongest artificial humans seen at the
time easily defeating a razor head and
seriously injuring all might to the
point where he couldn't walk he was
created as a counter to all might and
has been dubbed as a humanoid punching
bag because of his mix of quirks that
allow him to endure strong punches and
crippling injuries without hesitation
and speaking of punching bags can you
please do me a quick favor and punch
that like button right now for that
YouTube algorithm you can also subscribe
to the channel to help us reach 2
million subscrib subcribers we are
almost there now as well as having both
immense strength and speed the usj nomu
has two very powerful quirks built into
it to fulfill its purpose super
absorption and super regeneration with
super absorption he gains the ability to
withstand the shock of any strike but
there is a limit to how much he can
endure as we saw in that epic all might
moment and with super regeneration he
can recuperate from serious injuries in
seconds going as far as being a able to
regrow whole limbs instantly next up is
the very noce lady N Gun the pro hero
turned villain turned hero again's
original Quirk is a very unique and
amazing one in itself but it is further
enhanced by the quirks all for one G
after her escape from Tartarus lady
Nagant has the ability to extend a rifle
from her right elbow through a hole in
her Palm she puts bullet rounds into the
weapon her effective range is 3 km and
she can also boost the velocity of her
her rounds by substantially raising the
power output of the rifle causing the
gun barrel to grow and bulge out however
in doing so it does increase the chance
of the gun jamming now for extra
accuracy she can also stretch a tendril
from her gun and coil it up to make a
sight rifle also enables her to plug
strands of her hair which she can twist
and mold like epoxy putty and firm to
make different sorts of bullets bullets
such as hollow point bullets and curved
bullets additionally these hair bullets
can also record her voice and
rebroadcast a message once they strike
now lady nagan also got the Quirk
Airwalk from all for one as payment for
going after isuku midor Airwalk lets the
user stand on and manipulate the air
surrounding them allowing them to
levitate because the user is not tied to
the ground Airwalk allows more mobility
and stronger offense and evasive
abilities The Quirk has the ability to
float straight up as well as stroll and
skip on invisible air platforms while in
midair she typically uses her quirk in
conjunction with her rifle Quirk
allowing her to swiftly switch sniping
positions and pursue her Target
substantially increasing the range of
her bullets then there was an unnamed
exploding Quirk where lady nag gant's
body could be detonated from afar by all
for one causing a large explosion and
leaving her scorched all for one
secretly gave this to Lady nagan as a
backup plan in case she changed her mind
about aiding her
now it's unclear whether all for one has
any control over the transmitted Quirk
or if he employs a separate Quirk to
make lady nagar explode now we're moving
on to the top 10 starting with daero
banjo who had five generations of
accumulated power with one for all as
well as his own Quirk black whip one for
all was passed down to daero from hikage
and it of course allowed him to amass a
vast amount of raw power allowing him to
dramatically augment all of his physical
talents to superhuman levels this
resulted in Incredible strength speed
agility and
durability and then there was his own
Quirk black whip black whip grants the
power to create and command energy
tendrils from any area of the body these
tendrils are dark black with faint teal
accents this Quirk is fueled by emotions
namely anger which means that the more
Angry you are the stronger the Quirk
gets now because its strength is related
to the user's emotions black whip can be
difficult to manage as Dao says that it
isn't a quirk to be used carelessly The
Quirk itself looks to be effective for
capturing foes as well as enhancing
Mobility by gripping onto things
according to diro himself black whip is
a top tier Quirk next up we have another
one for all user in all might's mentor
and big Shy's grandmother Nana Shima who
had seven generations of accumulated
power with one for all as well as their
own floating Quirk one for all as we
discussed with diro allowed Nana to
amass a huge amount of royal power
enhancing her physical attributes to
again yes superhuman levels this boosted
of course her strength speed agility and
durability one for all was passed down
to Nana from n as for her own Quirk that
was called float not to be mistaken with
uraraka's Quirk is actually more like
that of Lady Nag's airw walk Nana's
Quirk Ena her to suspend herself in
midair it's unclear whether she was able
to maneuver herself while levitating pre
one for all of course float gains far
greater power with the addition of the
stored energy from one for all allowing
the user to fly at high speeds coming in
at number eight in the strongest
multiple Quirk users in mha is another
nomu but this time in hood hood was one
of Dr gak's 12 intelligent high-end nomu
and the major oppon opponent of the Pro
Hero Arc battling against Endeavor and
Hawks Hood had six different quirks
which were muscle augmentation shoulder
mounted Jets transforming arms power and
storage muscle augmentation is a quirk
that allows its user to amplify alter
and augment their muscle layers both
within and outside of their body
offering them Incredible strength speed
and durability it also allows the user
to compete with one for all at full
strength super regeneration can restore
any type of injury on the user's body
such as missing limbs at break neck
speed it's regarded as a very rare and
dangerous Quirk due to its ability to
render any of its users nearly
indestructible allowing them to recover
from practically any attack Dr gaki
created The Quirk artificially and
duplicated it several times to enhance
his nomu army with the objective of
achieving a Flawless version for all for
one shoulder mounted Jets allow their
user to fly faster by mounting four
retractable jet boosters on their upper
bag due to Hud's need to utilize his
transforming arms Quirk to sustain his
flight it's tough to maneuver utilizing
the flight Powers offered by this Quirk
now speaking of transforming arms
transforming arms enables the user to
shape shift their arms enabling long
ranged elastic attacks the user can also
separate their arms to surround the
Target and fire numerous assaults at the
same time as mentioned Hood could also
turn them into Wings to assist with his
flight power grants its user great
physical power capable of shattering a
reinforced concrete structure The Quirk
enabled his body to hold and unleash
tremendous physical raw Force allowing
him to augment his physical strength
even further he utilized this to boost
the power of His assaults and combine it
with other quirks to easily overwhelm
Endeavor and fling him into the top
stories of the skyscrapers Hood's final
Quirk was storage this Quirk appears to
Grant its Bearer the ability to store
and release various creatures within
their body at command Hood utilized it
to hold many white nomu within his body
and released them as reinforcements
while he battled Endeavor storage may
have a limit on how many objects may be
kept in the user's body since Hood was
able to store at least nine nomu and no
more although this is yet to be proven
along with hood we have to briefly
mention the other highend nomu which
appear in the later arcs of the story we
didn't get to see them showcasing their
abilities to the same extent as Hood so
it is hard to rank them reliably but
they are all extremely strong and they
deserve at least a mention in this video
next up in seventh place is nine the
main antagonist from the second my hero
Academia movie two Heroes now it is hard
to power scale movie characters as they
are not always 100% consistent with the
Canon storyline but we feel that he fits
in nicely here Nine's original Quirk was
weather manipulation weather
manipulation gives it use a complete
control over all forms of weather nine
had demonstrated his ability to generate
gigantic storm clouds that engulf entire
Islands summon lightning bolts and even
produce massive tornadoes this ability
also allowed him to manipulate wind and
even fly storms caused by this Quirk
were powerful enough to Gravely
devastate an entire Island now the great
power OFW manipulation placed an
enormous strain on the user's body
causing cellular deterioration as well
as agonizing pain that forced nine to
faint this vulnerability could be lethal
and this forced nine to use his Quirk
infrequently this impact became worse
once nine gained all for one and he
would ultimately surpass his limits if
he used all of his quirks at the same
time Nine's second Quirk was a weakened
version of all for one that could be
used to steal and hold up to eight other
quirks Dr gaki performed a surgical
transplant on him after he was
determined to be compact compatible with
all for one's Quirk Factor now it is
uncertain whether he was able to
transfer his stolen quirks to someone
else and the quirks that we saw him use
were air wall scanning bullet laser
Hydra and Cell Activation nine used air
wall to build a translucent barrier of
pressurized air around himself to
protect himself in a certain direction
this Quirk can also be utilized
offensively to repel individuals and
assaults by launching a strong Air Blast
this Quirk was very tough since it can
endure one for all at 100% through an
infrared like Vision NY used scanning to
recognize distinct quirks belonging to
others and acquire a read on their
abilities he can use this Quirk to
measure their different power levels to
some extent this gauging ability is
demonstrated as nine uses it to gauge
isuku midori's Rising physical strength
as he prepares to use a Detroit smash on
the villain with bullet laser nine can
fire purple colored lasers from his
fingertips tips at will this quir can
readily Pierce human flesh as well as
many other Solid Surfaces it also has
been demonstrated that it can explode
upon collision with certain surfaces The
Quirk Hydra has the ability to conjure
massive blue dragon shaped attacks from
Nine's back that he can control nine
often employs this Quirk as a longrange
weapon suspending or restraining
individuals he usually summons two at
once his final Quirk Cell Activation
enabled nine to stimulate cell in his
own or another person's body
accelerating regeneration and healing
any harm this version of The Quirk
however only worked on those with type A
blood now nine took this Quirk from the
Shimano sibling's father in order to
heal himself but it was in vain due to
the villain's incompatible type B blood
next up is heiko toga a major fan
favorite and one of the main antagonists
in the mha story toa's original Quirk
transform all allows her to turn into a
physical replica of another person and
mimic their speech she can only change
into humans whose blood she has consumed
once doing so she gets access to that
person's form for as long as she drinks
blood for example one cup of blood
allows her to change for 18 hours now if
she takes the blood of more than one
person she can flip between their looks
she can even imitate someone's outfit
however her own garments would overlap
the transition requiring her to strip
nude first when she deactivates her
Quirk or switches to another toa's
disguise dissolves into a gray liquid
now this is where toa's Quirk earns her
a place on this list of multiple Quirk
users during her battle with curious and
her men toa's Quirk awakened granting
her the power to use the quirks of the
individual she's turned into something
she was previously unable to accomplish
however toga can only utilize another
person's Quirk if she is captivated by
that person and keeps them near to her
heart and she must be well-versed in
their power now we saw toga use ururaka
zero gravity when her Quirk awakened but
earning her the sixth spot on this list
of multiple Quirk monsters is when she
uses twice's sadman's parade toga is
able to reproduced twice's iconic
ultimate move sadman's parade by
replicating double attacking her
opponents with countless doubles of
twice toga also uses sadman's death
parade to clone duplicates of herself
changed into twice with the explicit aim
of destroying anything and everything in
her path finally there was sadman's
Legion toga is able to produce a legion
of clones that take the look of many
heroes and villains whose blood was
stolen from the battlefield of the gunga
mountain Villa ruins entering the top
five strongest multiple Quirk users we
have none other than Derby whose real
name is Toya Todoroki and is another of
the main villains in all of mha Dobby's
Quirk blue flame allows him to produce
and control extremely destructive blue
flames from his body his Quirk which was
originally orange and red became blue
after going through a growth Sprout he
has very good control over his flames
and can project them far out and in
enormous quantities furthermore his
Flames are more powerful than his father
endeavor's hell flame Quirk and they
become even stronger when Dobby
experiences intense emotions Dobby's
body on the other hand has a poor
tolerance for his Flames because he
inherited his mother's resilience to
cold temperatures rather than his
father's resilience to intense heat and
thus he will get burnt if he utilizes
the Flames for an extended length of
time it can potentially be deadly if he
raises the temperature to its maximum
now let's talk about some of Derby's
incredible ultimate moves endeavor's
unique skill flash fire fist which was
eventually passed down to Derby boosts
the temperature of his fire to its
greatest setting maximizing his power
dabby can then unleash powerful flame
strikes or greatly enhance his speed
then there is Hell spider where dabby
scorches his opponents with jets from
fire from his fingertips Derby unlike
his father does things on a wider scale
and with less care and accuracy with jet
burn Derby can employ this attack to
launch a burst of fire at his Target
this move is incredibly powerful during
the struggle against the Paranormal
Liberation Front Derby utilized the
attack on his younger brother show so
Derby unlike his father just fires his
fire instead of making physical contact
with his opponent however during the
final war Arc he does use it in a
punching form similar to Endeavor again
against Shoto Dobby can use prominence
burn to send a powerful Focus blast of
fire from his entire body capable of
vaporizing his opponent Derby almost
utilized this move at full strength
against endava but was stopped by the
unexpected presence of best genus on the
battlefield dabby does reach his maximum
speed and temperature with this attack
Derby also has hell Minefield where he
pushes his Flames underground with blue
flame creating pillars of flame to rush
out of the earth scorching whatever is
in their path finally there is Vanishing
fist where Dobby summons a massive fire
fist and throws it at his opponent Dobby
performed this ultimate move by
exploding his own right arm but you're
thinking wait isn't this just one Quirk
with a boatload of ultimate mov moves
well yes but Dobby is on this list
because of events that occur during the
final war Arc so after losing his second
fight against Shoto blue flame strength
grew causing it to manifest the ice from
his mother's Quirk Frost within itself
now this power is actually characterized
as different from a quirk Awakening it's
a Russia power that appeared while he
was on the point of death to assist him
in surviving his horrific burns with
this Derby utilizes shoto's ultimate
move phosphor which was originally
intended to unite his Fire and Ice into
one strike to re-energize himself and
his Flames after being called Down by
Shoto the fourth strongest multiple
Quirk user is the absolute Beast that is
giganto Makia giganto Makia is a villain
from the league of villains he is a
loyal follower and former bodyguard of
alha one subsequently serving his
successor tomr shigaraki he became a
member of the Paranormal Liberation
Front after the league of villains
joined with the meta Liberation Army he
was apprehended following his loss in
the Paranormal Liberation War but during
the final war he escaped from prison and
allied with the heroes and according to
gaki gigant Makia has been upgraded with
six additional quirks that work in
tandem with his initial Quirk to make
him the ideal bodyguard now he possesses
a total of seven quirks and let's go
through them so giganto maka's original
Quirk endurance allows him to turn his
morale into to physical energy and
stamina giganto maia's second Quirk pain
blocker prevents him from feeling pain
his third Quirk gigantification allows
him to expand to enormous proportions
when angry or thrilled he can reach a
height of at least 25 M Kanto Maria's
fourth Quirk dog gives him an enhanced
sense of smell and hearing which is
comparable to a dock energy saver is
Gant maia's fifth Quirk and it allows
his body to work on extremely little
nutrients and fluids allowing him to
function completely on very little sleep
his sixth Quirk Fierce gains causes his
muscles to stiffen to an extraordinary
degree and finally ganto maia's seventh
Quirk which is called mole allows him to
develop mole likee Claws from his
fingers spines on his back and a visor
to assist him in digging into the Earth
and ripping through buildings
underground all for one gave him this
Quirk with the intention of hiding
underground now there aren't many who
would take on giganto Maka and there are
many on this list that wouldn't be able
to do it single-handedly but the top
three can more than hold their own in
combat against him however before we
move on to the top three strongest
multiple Quirk users let's look at some
honorable mentions first up we have
Shoto Todoroki with his Quirk half cold
half hot yes it's one Quirk but it has
two very distinct Powers almost as if
they were like two quirks themselves
half cold half hot is the result of a
quirk marriage between shoto's father en
todoroki's hellflame Quirk and his
mother Ray todoroki's Frost Quirk half
cold half hot enables Shoto to make ice
Frost and cold from the right side of
his body while also generating fire
flames and heat from the left however
Shoto cannot manipulate any element that
originates from outside of his body he
can only produce them from within the
power of the Quirk is evenly distributed
between shoto's right and left sides
this provides Shoto with two powerful
different fighting Tac tactics that he
can utilize regardless of the other
shoto's controlled growth of The Quirk
and control over his left side has
enabled him to mix his Fire and Ice into
a cold fire using his circuito system to
circulate the hot and cold blood around
his body so while his Quirk is like two
distinctive Powers he can also combine
them for an even more devastating effect
then we have overhaul and his Quirk of
the same name overhaul overhauls Quirk
grants him the power to Decon construct
and reassemble everything he touches
effectively giving him complete control
over the situation overhaul can
deconstruct individuals in order to kill
them or reassemble them in order to cure
their wounds he can do this to himself
and even fuse his body with the bodies
of others allowing him to use their
quirks it's his ability to fuse with
others and use their quirks to get him a
place in the honorable mentions next up
we have monar from class 1B and his
Quirk copy Mona's Quirk enables him to
copy and use the Quirk of another
individual after coming into physical
contact with the user he can carry four
quirks at the same time and copy those
abilities for 10 minutes when the timer
expires Mona loses the copied Quirk
until he touches the original user again
Mona now has complete control of the
Quirk he has cloned and may utilize it
in any way he sees fit however he cannot
employ many quirks at the same time just
one at a time though it does have its
limitations Mona is able to hold
multiple quirks at one time and it has
been used as a valuable asset during the
final war Arc next up is great explosion
murder God Dynamite AKA katsky bakugo
bakugo makes the list because of the
second mha movie where he temporarily
has one for all as well as his own Quirk
explosion deu transferred one for all to
bakugo allowing him to accumulate an
enormous amount of raw strength enabling
him to dramatically augment all of his
physical abilities to a superhuman level
this of course resulted in Incredible
strength speed agility and durability it
also gave his assigned Quirk explosion a
significant strength increase bakugo of
course lost one for all at the end of
his and deku's battle against nine and
The Quirk stayed in deku's body
toshinori assumed that Deku kept one for
all since bakugo lost Consciousness
before the transfer completion but
subsequently theorized that The Quirk
kept itself inside deu because of his
determination to protect others even if
it meant losing one for all itself the
final honorable mention goes to toshan
Nori yagi AKA all might and it's not
because of the Quirk one for all but
instead for the Iron Man esque battle
suit he wore during his fight with all
for one in the final war Arc where all
might was able to mimic the quirks of
all the students in class 1a I mean they
weren't technically quirks but
technology however we felt it was
awesome enough to deserve a mention
before we move on to the top three
strongest multiple Quirk users in the
world of mha so in third place we have
none other than the main protagonist of
the story isuku midorya AKA deu and his
Quirk one for all deu is the ninth
wielder of The Quirk one for all which
was transferred to him from all might
one for all allows him to store a vast
amount of raw strength allowing him to
dramatically boost all of those physical
attributes to potentially infinite
levels this produces astonishing levels
of strength speed stamina agility and
durability we've seu grow with his
ability to use one for all over the
course of the story being able to
control more percentages of one for
all's raw power creating his own styles
using it and using many an ultimate
Smash move for it but Deku gains a place
on this list when he is able to utilize
another aspect of one for all's power
The Quirk factors of the previous
wielders have fused with the the core of
one for all greatly enhancing their
strength this allows deu to access and
use the quirks of the past bearers of
one for all he can even utilize multiple
quirks at once giving him even more
choices in combat one for- all's known
quirks are as follows float is the
eighth user nanashima Quirk The Quirk
enables deu to hang himself in midair
allowing him to fly then there is the
sixth user ends Quirk smokescreen this
Quirk enables Deku to expel a dead cloud
of purple smoke from his body this smoke
May cover a large area and impair
people's Vision digo banjo the fifth
users Quirk black whip allows isuku to
emit tendrils of black energy from his
body it is effective for longdistance
grabbing capturing opponents and
enhancing isuku Mobility the fourth use
are hikage shin mori's Quirk danger
sense allowed isuku to identify hazards
in the immediate environment the
detection caused a stabbing pain in it
head and took a toll on his body due to
the amplification of one for all now
during the final war Arc shigaraki stole
this Quirk from him then there is Bruce
the third users Quirk Farin this Quirk
enables isuku to accumulate and retain
kinetic energy through recurrent
movement he can then unleash this
accumulated energy in the form of an
explosive burst of speed and power
finally the second user Kudos Quirk
gearshift isuku can adjust the speed and
velocity of any Target he touches even
himself this enables him to
significantly increase his own speed or
the velocity of his Target as well as
increased the impact power of his own
hits gearshift has grown into quite an
odd power that cannot be handled in its
typical way due to the years of being
enhanced within one for all because of
this it is said to be used as a last
result the second strongest multiple
Quirk user in mha is all for one once
Japan's most power power ful villain and
all might's arch nemesis his ultimate
objective was to steal one for all the
Quirk that belonged to his younger twin
brother the only Quirk that is capable
of opposing him and his overwhelming
Quirk all for one all for one's Quirk
enables him to take other people's
quirks rendering them quirkless and
wield them as his own all for one can
also pass on his stolen quirks to others
his numerous quirks provide him a wide
range of fighting options and he can
combine his stolen quirks to produce
comb ation assaults with catastrophic
results he cannot however take the
original users Quirk proficiency and
thus is constrained by his own expertise
with his acquired skills as a result he
prefers to steal quirks that rely on
sheer power rather than those that need
work and expertise to master to take a
quirk he must also physically touch the
user's body as touching something
created by a quirk such as a fire users
Flames is insufficient or for one has
stolen a huge huge amount of quirks over
his time and it is impossible to name
every single one of them but let's have
a look at some of the quirks that we do
know about spear-like bones or for one's
body is surrounded by drill-like bone
structures thanks to this Quirk or for
one took this Quirk from his mother when
he was born and it is his first overall
search All For One stole this Quirk from
ragd doll he can see and monitor up to a
100 individuals at once with this Quirk
including their location and weak areas
warping Al for one can generate a black
liquid that operates as a Gateway much
like kurogiri's warp gate he has the
ability to deploy this Quirk on a wide
scale creating many black liquid portals
this Quirk on the other hand has some
limitations it's not a coordinated based
warping and can only warp items to and
from his positions it also has a
restricted range and operates only on
those with whom he has a tight
relationship with air cannon all for one
unleashes an air tsunami from his arms
this Quirk is boosted much more when
paired with spring-like Limbs and
numerous other PowerUp quirks speaking
of spring-- like limbs this Quirk allows
oral one to coil his muscles to increase
his physical power it can also be used
to supplement other quirks such as air
cannon rivet stab All For One turns his
fingers into black tendrils with red
prominent cracked lines that spread from
his fingertips however they can also
Sprout from other areas of his body
including the spine these appendages can
readily Pierce bodies but the user has
the option of wounding or not wounding
the victim as witnessed when all for one
utilized it with forced Quirk activation
without injuring the target again
speaking of forced Quirk activation
whether a victim is aware or not Al for
one can activate their Quirk against
their will like mentioned this Quirk has
been employed by Al for one in
conjunction with rivet stab now these
are just a mere few of the quirks all
for one has used but it goes without
saying that this guy was an absolute
monster and very well-deserving of a
second place on this list and we should
also mention here that his placing is
when he was at his prime this is before
he got his injury in his battle against
all might so we we are talking Prime all
for one right here so I guess you're
thinking who tops a prime all for one
well you know who it's going to be but I
thought I'd at least try and hype it up
a bit you know so the strongest multiple
Quirk user in all of mha is of course
none other than the insane Beast that is
tomora shigaraki the main villain and
big evil of the series his original
Quirk is Decay Decay allows the user to
destroy everything or anybody that their
hands come into contact with causing it
to disintegrate to dust and powdered
bone it like AR's rewind is the
consequence of a rare mutation that no
one knew about before it emerged Decay
will always function whether the target
is organic or not as a result this Quirk
is exceedingly harmful to living beings
causing their flesh to rot if they were
hit by it the rate of disintegration has
increased from sluggish to practically
instantaneous ultimately spreading
throughout the entire body if a victim
does not amputate the rotting body part
decay's influence can also expand beyond
what the user has touched resulting in a
chain reaction of disintegrating victims
now toor's Decay has reawakened and
gotten stronger over the course of the
series but it became significantly more
powerful after his surgery where he
received his second Quirk that second
Quirk was none other than all for one
itself toor's second Quirk is his
master's original version of All For One
it enables him to take other people's
quirks and pass them off as his own this
Quirk like its twin Quirk one for all
retains the vestage of its former
wielder will and awareness unlike one
for all however the Vestal will of its
former owner wants to take over Tom's
Body by utilizing his negative emotions
like rage and hatred as a catalyst this
renders the relationship between past
and current users parasitic rather than
symbolic tomra on the other hand is able
to restore control of both his body and
The Quirk itself with enough resolve so
let's look at some of the quirks
shigaraki has used using all for one
super regeneration toor has the capacity
to heal from any injury at a rapid Pace
allowing to survive Endeavors hell flame
now the original version of toor was
injured during the struggle against star
and stripe leading to a malfunction as a
result he replaced it with one of the
near high-ends versions search tomora
has ragd doll's old Quirk which allows
him to see up to 100 people at once he
can see them from afar and through
concealing obstacles this Quirk also
enables him to pinpoint their weak areas
air cannon tomor has the ability to
discharge enormous bursts of pressurized
air from the palms of his hands radio
waves toor has the ability to disrupt
radio waves causing Communications to
malfunction rivet stab as an offensive
technique toor generates black tendrils
with red noticeable cracked lines from
his hands and spine stabbing Endeavor
and bucko with them heavy payload toor
appears to be able to boost the amount
of damage done scatter toor has the
ability to break apart projectiles
causing them to scatter all over the
place spring like limbs TOA can coil his
muscles allowing him to increase his
physical power and Propel himself into
the air Wing taken from a near high-end
nomu this Quirk provides toor the
ability to fly by sprouting black wings
from his back danger ends taken from
Deku and one for all this Quirk allows
Tom to identify and respond to
surrounding hazards so tomra shigaraki
is a terrifying monster and his own
Quirk Decay combined with the power of
all for one makes him the deadliest foe
out there and the strongest multiple
Quirk user in the entire series and that
is our list of the strongest multiple
Quirk users in my hero Academia what do
you think of our list do you agree with
our rankings let us know in the comment
section below if you want another mha
video to check out after this one then
why not check out our video where we
look into what would have happened if
deu turned into a villain link on screen
and in the description if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to see more
mha videos on the channel make sure to
let us know by Smashing that like button
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime uo videos but that's
all for now we'll see you in the next
video peace